Oh
[Music]
all right good evening everybody welcome
back to Gd 50 this is lecture 6
and today we're going to be venturing
out of the 8-bit world and back into
sort of a more modern era of gaming
we're talking about Angry Birds today I
have pretty fond memories of Angry Birds
actually it was the first sort of mobile
game that I remember playing where I
sort of realized that mobile was
actually a viable platform for gaming I
played it I think back in 2009 was when
it was first released and I really
enjoyed it it has a very simple formula
the goal if you're unfamiliar is you
have birds that you sort of controlled
by a slingshot on the left side of the
screen and then these pigs that have
stolen your eggs you're trying to sort
of destroy them or kill them by knocking
down their fortresses made out of
various materials wood glass metal and
you get a few different bird types but
the gist of it is basically just
slingshot a bird into some structure
knock it down and the whole entire sort
of underlying mechanism for how things
work is via a physics engine which we'll
talk about today in lecture called box2d
probably the most ubiquitous 2d physics
engine but that's sort of like the
overall sort of structure of the game
it's literally just throwing things into
structures knocking them down and then
that sort of tactile and fun gameplay
mix for really great mobile gaming and I
enjoyed it a lot back in the day this is
this is a screenshot of the first level
in the first Angry Birds which most
people I think have probably seen this
is a sort of a sample from one of their
newer games as you can see it's kind of
taken a whole new layer here there's
stone and a bunch of varying of
completely varying structures and new
creatures and stuff like that the game
has changed a lot but the formula has
stayed the same and today we'll sort of
explore the foundation of what makes
this game work and the topics today a
smaller list than usual but box 2d we
can sort of consider as being a pretty
large topic we'll be talking about box
2d which is the physics engine we'll be
using today in lecture and vial of 2d
which has its own wrapper for box 2d
I'll also talk about a little bit about
Mouse input which you haven't really
done a lot but it's very apt especially
in the context of mobile gaming because
my mouse input and
and put our synonymous but first that's
got a lecture demo if we have a have a
volunteer come up on stage to showcase
what I've put together here so let me
make sure I'm in the right directory
here alright so whenever you're ready go
ahead and press Enter
so this is a little demo I put together
demonstrates the concepts we'll talk
about today in class this is just a
start screen but it already shows box2d
sort of representing a bunch of these
square shape aliens which will actually
be what we're trying to target in the
game but notice that they all sort of
fell and had their own collision and
their own physics that sort of took
place and I didn't have to manually code
like rotation and stuff like this this
is all stuff that box2d
takes care of for us and we'll see it
used to great effect soon so if you go
ahead and just click on anywhere on the
screen we'll go to the main sort of part
of the game so this is a very simple
representation of what Angry Birds is
you start on the left side of the screen
you have a bird in this case an alien
we're used a free art pack that uses
aliens instead of birds but it's the
same concept you have an alien that you
can click and drag us if you click it
and then drag around you can see the
sort of trajectory that you'll have when
you when you let go of the mouse so
we're simulating where it's going to go
via these purple circles and then the
goal in Angry Birds is to you know sort
of throw the bird in to or the alien
into the fortress guarding the pigs or
in this case square shaped aliens so if
you go ahead and just launch the verb I
let him go the mouse you'll see oh there
we go and we knock down the okay so the
what happened was we shot the AI we shot
the alien into the structure it
destroyed one of the wooden pieces of
one of the wooden blocks guarding the
other alien and then as soon as that
happened the top bought a box because
these are all being simulated by a box
to DS physics engine that other box was
detected as being unsupported so it fell
down it hit the other alien and we've
coated it so that when a collision
occurs between an obstacle and our alien
of sufficient speed it should kill the
alien which is sort of how it works in
Angry Birds
so if we try it again and this time we
hit both of those at the same time so
it's triggered both of those being
deleted but this guy is still alive so
after it stops moving which is similar
to how it behaves in the original game
it's gonna let us try again to shoot so
each if we try one more time and then we
launch and hit it we kill it and then we
get a victory and so that's the overall
sort of underlying foundation for what
Angry Birds is obviously we're using a
very simple representation it doesn't
have a lot of the thrill that Angry
Birds does but we could easily build
upon this and create a fully fleshed out
game very similar to Angry Birds so
thanks Stephen appreciate the
demonstration all right so that's our
goal today we'll be talking about how to
construct a sort of very basic but
functional simulation of what Angry
Birds is at its core which is just
flinging things into obstacles
destroying them and ultimately
destroying the things that they're
protecting the aliens two pigs that are
in the base game so here's what here's a
shot of what the different sprite sheets
we're gonna be using are there's a
really great sprite sheet that I got off
of open game art Kenny is the artist he
makes a lot of great art if you notice
it's very similar looking to the art
that we used in the mario lecture
actually it's the same artist so if
you're ever looking for assets he's got
a ton of awesome assets on open game art
so we have a set of aliens Square and
round shaped I decided just arbitrarily
we made the round shaped aliens the
birds so we shoot those into the
structures they're protecting the square
shaped aliens the square shape aliens
will be the sort of the bad guys in this
case and then we have another sprite
sheet down here below on the left side
which just I used the tile here just to
make a ground element the rest of these
you could easily include in the game if
you wanted to but we are only using the
ground here and then notice here we have
this large sprite sheet which has a
bunch of different shapes and sizes of
materials this the whole sprite she
comes with metal and explosive and glass
sheets as well but just for simplicity
we only use the wood here but notice
that we have
like entirely whole pieces and then we
have pieces that are partially destroyed
and then pieces that are Hollow you
could easily model all of these in your
game and use them but we only decided to
use just a couple of these which was
just the horizontal and the vertical
ones that are completely whole they
these unfortunately don't have quite the
same sort of systematic layout as the
sprites that we used before they're not
laid out in a grid evenly spaced so in
this case in utila WA I ended up hard
coding the different XY width and height
quads for each of these which is kind of
what you have to do in the situation
where you're interacting not with tiles
per se but with more organic shaped
objects so it can take a little more
time to end up constructing all of the
quads for your objects when you have a
sprite you like this but fortunately you
only have to do it once so here's a few
useful links before we get started and
talking about what box 2d is and how to
use it and basically how it's called
loved physics effectively in love 2d the
first two links are documentation for
love 2d sort of what the functions and
objects are that we'll be talking about
and a simple tutorial that talks about
how to make a ball bounce in love 2d
using box2d the third is a great
resource that I used actually to learn
most of what I know about box 2d
especially in the context of this this
lecture so it talks about a lot of
different concepts talked about all the
things that we'll be talking about and
then it goes into a lot more detail
about how you can go about constructing
a lot of really cool crazy things like
tanks and pulleys and a whole bunch of
different things that are worth looking
into if you're looking into potentially
making a physics based game obviously we
won't be going into you know things of
that complexity here but you could
easily do it with box 2d it makes it
very very possible so the very first
thing that we should talk about when we
want to construct a game or a simulation
or whatever we want to do with box 2d is
we need some sort of system that will
actually perform the simulation for us
and the fundamental core of what a box
2d app or game is
the core is the world object so there is
a world that you can think of as sort of
being your world but what it effectively
is is a machine that simulates all of
the pieces that you've told it interact
with each other in box2d
so box2d has a set of objects called
fixtures and bodies those perform the
physical interactions and it's up to the
world to update all of those and apply
the relevant forces and physics
calculations that resolve collisions and
do all sorts of things all of the things
that box2d does for us the world takes
care of this for us so we don't have to
manually go through and update every
single object with its velocity that
we've done before and check for
collisions the world does this for us
and resolves them based on how we tell
it to resolve them and the world also
possesses like in actual world would
gravity on the X and y axis in this case
we have gravity applied on the y axis
going down so it's a positive value we
set it to 300 in this district but you
can set it to whatever you want setting
a lower gravity would have the effect of
you know making it to feel like we're on
the moon or something making it feel
like we're on a different planet so
that's what the world is the world
simulates everything and we'll go
through just a few terms here before you
look at some source code but there's a
few terms that we need to sort of
understand before we can really
understand what box2d is doing and this
is the function that we use to create a
new world in love 2d very simple love
dot physics new world and this love dot
physics is just a namespace that
encapsulates everything that box that it
encapsulates all of the box 2d functions
and objects that love 2d has access to
so anything that you see in love dot
physics is effectively a wrapper for box
2d and a clarify about box 2d box 2d is
just a library that's written in C++
that you can plug in pretty much
anywhere you want to unity uses it and
most actually most 2d game engines that
I've ever seen including libgdx for
example which is a very large java 2-d
game framework uses box 2d you can use
it anywhere in this case we are using
love to DS own wrapper for it so the
people that created love 2d they
took box2d and then they just put a
bunch of Lua functions around them
around all the objects and functions to
make it possible to use it in the same
style that we use the rest of the
framework so this is how you create a
new world this is the first step in
getting your box 2d simulation sort of
working so any questions so far that's
how we get that going okay
so beyond the world object which is the
sort of the foundation sort of sets up
our stage you can think of it as our
stage we need bodies to actually
interact with each other so a body is
just an abstract container it basically
holds a position and a velocity and you
attach things to it via what are called
fixtures that allow you to give the body
a shape and therefore a collision box
and therefore allow it to interact with
other things but a body body is
essentially all the disparate things in
your scene that interact with each other
and move around and so to create a new
body we just do love dot physics dot new
body and we pass in the world
so therefore when we do this the world
has a reference to this body now and
every time we call update on our world
which we'll see in the source code it
will know okay I have a reference to
this body perform all of the relevant
you know checks on the collision for
that body and all the fixtures that it
contains update its position updates
velocity and and so forth and it not
only a world but it also gets an X and a
Y which will place it in the world on
instance the instantiation the last
parameter here type there are three
fundamental types of bodies which we'll
see in love 2d static dynamic and
kinematic and that basically influences
how it'll interact with the other
objects the other bodies in our scene so
we have the world which encapsulate
everything all the bodies all the
fixtures and then we have the bodies
which are the entities in our game world
that have position and velocity
effectively
the last sort of key ingredient here
that will allow us to create
interactions between the bodies that we
have are fixtures and fixtures all a
fixture is is sort of this abstract
object that will allow you to attach a
shape to a body so bodies are shaped
list by default they don't have a shape
they are just a container that has
position velocity effectively but they
don't interact with anything else and
they don't know how to interact with
anything else until you give them a
fixture and the fixture you will give
the body and a shape so for example
layfie you want the bird that we were
looking at earlier the alien the round
alien we create a body for it in our
world which doesn't mean anything yet
but we say I'm gonna attach a fixture to
that alien I'm gonna give it a circle
shape and it'll then know whenever it
performs any calculations that that
alien should interact with things as if
it were round and therefore trigger
collisions based on a circular hitbox as
opposed to a rectangular or polygonal
hitbox as we'll see fixtures in addition
to attaching shapes to bodies which will
as set here influence how they collide
with other bodies they have density
which we'll see so that you know things
with higher density obviously will fall
faster or not fall faster but they will
influence things with as if they have
more weight they will push things
farther when they collide with them they
also have friction and they have
restitution restitution is bounciness so
something if we have our alien no
restitution when it hits the ground
it'll just kind of fall flat but if we
give it a higher restitution it'll
actually bounce when it hits the ground
and therefore and interact with the
world a little bit differently so when
we want to take a fixture and apply a
shape to a body we have a few different
shapes that we can apply to it that are
given to us by default and love 2d so
circle shape rectangle shape edge shape
these are just effectively how we define
how our bodies interact with other
bodies how you know for example if it's
something is circular it should roll
when it's you know moving along
the ground or you know when it hits
something the corner obviously of it
won't hit something because it's rounded
as opposed to something that has a
square hit box it'll affect things in a
slightly different way and we can define
arbitrarily shaped hit boxes thanks to
the polygon shape if we want something
to be you know shaped like a Pentagon
for example and have it roll around and
behave like such we can just define a
polygon via a set of vertices and then
fix that to a body and it'll behave as
if it were Pentagon shaped
and this is how you would instantiate G
so just as we've seen with love that
physics not a new world and love that
physics not a new body love dot physics
that new fixture takes in a body and a
shape and will apply that shape to the
body and the world after that we'll know
exactly how to collide with things and
so the last thing we'll the last slide
we'll look at here before we start
looking at source code is what the
different body types are so I alluded to
the having three different body types
before static dynamic and kinematic so a
static body will exist in our world but
not actually be affected by gravity or
the collision of anything else things
can hit it and bounce off of it and do
their own thing but the static body will
never be influenced by something else it
exists as some sort of permanent
structure almost like the ground you
know you don't really affect the ground
by moving into it and bouncing into it
unless you do it with enough force but
in our box2d world a static body cannot
be influenced by anything else a dynamic
body is the opposite it is it has the
full sort of simulation of box2d it has
gravity affects it things collide into
it it will bounce off of them it'll do
what you would expect a normal body to
do if I throw a ball in this room and it
hits the wall it's a dynamic body the
walls are the static bodies in this case
and then a kinematic body is sort of a
hybrid between the two it's something
that can move and can you know sort of
rotate and do things but it's not
influenced by other behave other objects
colliding with it so for example if I
have a platform that's just spinning
indefinitely but it's not being affected
by gravity and it doesn't move when I
hit it that's a kinematic body it still
move
and it's semi static and it influences
other things but it's not purely static
it does have a little bit of behavior
that we can grant it so let's go ahead
and look at a few examples now and see
how this actually looks in code so I'm
gonna go into an example if you're
looking in the distro there is a an
example called static so we'll take a
look here and see what a static body
looks like in our scene and for all of
these examples leading up to Angry Birds
were just gonna render everything with
shapes for simplicity but this as
anti-climactic as it is is a full box 2d
world with just a single static body and
it's just this square here colored white
the static body doesn't move it doesn't
do anything nothing can influence how it
moves or you know behaves but it exists
in our world as a permanent fixture and
if we had dynamic bodies and we threw a
dynamic body at it for example the
dynamic body would bounce off the static
body would stay there permanently so
let's go ahead and take a look at what
the source code looks like for that so
I'm here in main Lua of our static file
and just as we've seen before we need to
define a world so I have a world here on
line 45 love dot physics to a new world
no exil gravity but we are going to have
300 units of positive gravity on the y
axis which is going from top to bottom
we need a body for our square arc that's
in our game roll or static square so
we're gonna go ahead and define a new
body here love dot physics dot new body
takes in the world recall because that's
how our world's gonna have a reference
to that body it doesn't know about it
unless we pass it into here our new body
constructor and then I'm just gonna put
it right in the middle of the screen so
virtual with / - a virtual height / -
the difference between
box2d bodies and things that we've drawn
before seen before is that everything is
defined by its center point as opposed
to its top left so I'm able to diff'ent
to say virtual / - and virtual height /
- here but I don't actually need to say
virtual width / 2 - whatever the half of
that square is by default the center
point is the
the XY of that object and this last
string here in the constructor for our
new body
static tells the constructor that this
is going to be a static body
specifically not a dynamic body and not
a kinematic body so we have a body and
it's you know it's static but it doesn't
have a shape it doesn't really know how
to interact with anything else in our
world so we're gonna give it a we're
gonna create a new shape first so love
gives us a few functions in the form of
new X shape we have a new rectangle
shape new circle shape new edge shape a
few other ones we're just gonna create a
new rectangle of size of width and
height of 10 that's where the tenant n
are here then we're going to create a
new fixture we're going to fix the box
shape to our body with this function and
then once we do that all we have to do
is then render a polygon with fill and
then we get the coordinates for our the
vertices for our polygon by saying body
get world points so that's a function
off of any love or any box2d body that
will basically get where it is in the
world and all of its vertices and then
use pass in the shape that you want to
get the points for and that will end up
just exploding here into a set of
vertices that fill up this love dot
graphics dot polygon and the end result
of that is we get a square and it's we
specifically use polygon instead of love
dot graphics that new rectangle because
that's what the get world points
function explodes out to it doesn't
explode out to the number of arguments
that would satisfy loved a graphic start
rectangle so not a very exciting example
but this is like the found this is
basically of the foundation of a full
box 2d application so any questions as
to how sort of this works at all
the center of an abnormal shape I'm not
entirely sure the circle is just it's
yeah I'm not entirely sure about a
polygon though I haven't looked into
that into too much detail I can I can
explore that and see and that's
something like that I think box 2d is
that like the actual library implements
that and like calculates that probably
based upon like calculating the area of
a to repeat for the camera if if I
didn't repeat already it's like how does
box 2d calculate the center point of
something non symmetrical like a polygon
and best I can understand is that it
would do an area calculation off of it
and you know sort of figure out where
all the vertices sort of like tend
towards I guess but yeah it's something
that's implemented in the library I'm
not entirely sure I can look into it and
see and then I'll post in the slack yeah
if if it were yeah if it we did have an
odd shape to get it placed in a exact
spot yeah I'm not entirely sure I'd have
to explore that a little bit interesting
idea though
but yeah that's essentially how we get a
box 2d world up and running we have a
static body it's not terribly
interesting but with one change so I
have a separate example called dynamic
in the source code distro but all we
need to do to really see the difference
from the static and dynamic body is on
line 48 just change static to dynamic
save it and then rerun it and then we'll
immediately see that it's affected by
gravity and it moves downwards as we've
told the world that our gravity is set
to positive 300 and so that behaves sort
of how we would expect it to now there's
nothing else in the scenes is not
particularly interesting so I've created
another example called ground
so let's go ahead and look at that so if
we want more interesting behavior what
do we need to do in a nutshell some more
shapes and make a ground exactly that's
a simple way we can start get instantly
a sense of how powerful box2d is just
introduce more shapes that interact with
each other in different ways so ground
is an example that just introduces a
ground into our scene so that we can see
the box fall down and actually collide
with something else and love 2d makes
this nice and easy excuse me they have a
actual edge shape that will allow us to
basically form the where the ground is
anything that collides with this it's a
it's effectively a line but the no
matter how fast anything moves in our
scene the the body will not move past
that line so it's a nice easy way of
getting a ground in our scene without
having to implement like a polygon that
maybe has like two vertices going left
to right on the screen so that's what we
do here we have a ground body which is a
static body recall because the ground
shouldn't move the we're gonna change
the the box into a dynamic body but the
ground shouldn't move the ground should
be unaffected by anything it's gonna be
static in our scene and it's gonna take
and it's gonna have an edge shape so
notice here we take zero zero as the X Y
and then a virtual width and zero so
with shapes shapes when we define them
here they aren't actually it's not going
to draw the shape at zero zero at
virtual width and zero this is relative
to wherever the body is located so
wherever our body is this shape will be
drawn with these coordinates this x and
y and this width and height relative to
that and specifically relative to the
center point of wherever we place a body
so if this ground is you know set to
zero zero at virtual width and zero
where do we need to place the actual
body for it to render
ground appropriately yeah so we place it
towards the middle bottom so we actually
end up placing the body itself here at
virtual height minus 30 and when we have
fix this edge shape to the body we'll
end up even though this says 0 0 virtual
width 0 its relative to wherever the
bodies XY are so it's actually going to
be 0 virtual height minus 30 virtual
with zero will be sort of where that
edge exists and then lastly just as we
did with our box we need a ground
fixture so that the ground body knows
how it should interact with other things
so we're going to a fix the edge shape
which is just a line to our ground body
and then here we do love graphics just
as we did up with a love dog graphics op
polygon for our box we're gonna do love
dog graphics dot line for our ground
body and we're going to do the exact
same thing get world points and get
points passing the edge shape here and
that I'm also setting a line width of
two just so we can see it a little bit
better and I'm going to color it red
Jenna colored the the box up here green
so go ahead and take a look at what this
looks like so I'm gonna go into ground
and so notice and I also added a little
bit of restitution to the as I said
before restitution is a quality that a
fixture can have which gives it
bounciness so rather than just falling
flat down onto the ground it bounces a
little bit as well and we can see the
interaction so I'll play it one more
time it starts in the middle and then as
soon as it hits the ground body that
we've created before the edge shape it
bounces a couple times but it shows that
the box is dynamic but the ground is
static nothing influences the position
of the ground it gets hard set and will
stay there permanently so that shows a
nice sort of easy simple demonstration
of an interaction between a static and a
dynamic body I'm gonna go ahead and pull
up a another example here so kinematic
recall what was the
sort of difference between a kinematic
and a static or dynamic body correct so
a kinematic body can move you can
ascribe it positional velocity or
angular velocity its rotation but when
something collides with it it's not
going to be influenced by it it's going
to influence the body that it collides
with it's going to affect it in some way
but nothing colliding with the kinematic
body is gonna have an effect on its
position or its velocity it's something
that exists and does something
programmed and we'll just do that
indefinitely but it will interact with
other dynamic bodies as we have
programmed and will not interact with
other kinematic bodies either they'll
almost pretend that each other doesn't
exist if you overlap a static and a
kinematic body or a kinematic and a
kinematic body they render on top of
each other but they don't actually
influence each other's position or
anything like that so I'm gonna go ahead
and run the kinematic example so so here
we have a few things going on so it's a
we have the Box body that we had before
the dynamic box that falls from the
middle of the screen we have the ground
on the very bottom to catch it but we
have three kinematic boxes in the very
center that are spinning that influence
the green box when the green box
collides with them so as you can see it
sort of tosses it around and then the
green body falls back to the bottom and
in this example I've taken away its
restitution so it just as soon as it
hits the ground it just sort of falls
flat just like that and so as you can
see these blue bodies they're moving
they have angular velocity indefinitely
specifically 360 degrees per second and
they will stay in that exact position
and rotate in that exact way forever but
as soon as they interact with a dynamic
body they actually cause a collision
with that dynamic body and the collision
resolves and the this green body gets
tossed around because it's dynamic it
will do it'll basically do whatever it
can to
interact with the game world as long as
it's interacting with other bodies and
resolving its collision that way and so
that's the sort of the key example
between what the three different bodies
are fundamentally and with these three
body types you can construct pretty much
any scene that you want to and obviously
the bodies and the fixtures can get
insanely complex I mean we can look back
here at our at this first example like
these structures are a composition of
many different types of of static body
oil dynamic bodies that have been given
sort of anchors and joints and all sorts
of other things to make them look as if
their legs big constructions but at the
end they're all just a bunch of little
bodies that are welded together fixtures
that are welded together and these
fundamental building blocks are sort of
how you construct scenes like this put a
bunch of these blocks together weld them
together with box to these joints in
this case we won't cover joints in the
context of this lecture but if you're
wondering how you know all of these
individual things can be you know
collidable while still constructing
these massive scenes and having physics
apply to them they're just jointed
together using weld joints or you know
other types of joints pulley joints
depending on what they are in this case
there's a the two circle circle shapes
here circle circle fixtures that are the
wheels on this cart and then they're
welded to the flat sort of constructions
here but that's allowing those to be
dynamic allows the wheels to roll and
therefore carry the other load with it
you know same with this bridge these are
I forget the exact name of the joint but
it's a chain of fixtures together that
are welded by a specific kind of joint
and by putting them together in this way
you get a sort of bridge and you know
all sorts of things that you could think
of including tanks which is in the the
notes here this third link there's one
of one of them talks about how to
implement a tank by having tread
going around circles and them in like a
massive body like you could do anything
with box2d it's a it's an awesome
library the context in the context of
Angry Birds really we just scratch the
surface for what is possible here so I'm
going to demo now actually I enjoyed I
think this demo this bit of code more
than I enjoyed the Angry Birds
implementation and it's a program that I
wrote called ball pit so oh by the way
before I get into that so I'll leave
that as a little teaser I guess looking
at kinematic really quickly we're going
to look and see that I've created a
table for the kinematic bodies a table
for the fixtures and then one shape
because you only need one shape actually
and you can apply one shape to as many
bodies as you want to as long as they
all have the same shape I just create
three kinematic bodies here so spacing
them out relative to the center with
this math here they get the string
kinematic and that's really the key
difference and then before finishing I
make sure that I set them to have an
angular velocity so this is how you spin
something if you want to set something
to spin indefinitely just set an angular
velocity in this case 360 times degrees
to radians and that's just a formula a
written out as a constant which is just
the number
I forget offhand what exactly the
formula is but it's up here it's
decreased rating zero point zero one
seven four five three to nine etc but
just like pi it's a it's a number that
you can use to multiply a number in
degrees and you'll get a number in
radians and there's the reverse up there
as well we have to do this because box2d
expects for any types of rotation
expects in radians
I prefer thinking in degrees so I passed
in 360 times degrees to radians and so
we render down here just as we did with
the Box body we render the kinematic
bodies polygons fill kinematic bodies at
I get world points kinematic shape get
points nothing terribly different
the only real key difference is that
we've added kin
as a string to the constructor for the
body and we've added some angular
velocity and recall this will make it
spin indefinitely but it will never be
influenced its angular velocity will
never be influenced its position will
never be influenced by anything else in
our scene so now with that out of the
way I'm gonna pull up ball pit so and
maybe I'm just a little bit too excited
about this but I enjoyed this this a lot
so what it is is this is sort of like a
bigger demonstration of you know putting
all these pieces together we have a
bunch of you know circle shapes they're
all interacting with each other they all
have physics and then I have a larger
shape here this square which has a
higher density than everything else and
by pressing spacebar I can just dive
into a head you know throw it into the
ball pit and it'll interact it'll cause
an interaction with everything else and
a bug slash feature that I discovered
about this is that if you press spacebar
over and over again
it never resets its velocity so it just
slams down into the ball pit so just
kind of fun and I think there might
actually be like possibly a game idea in
here but I mean well but what are the
pieces here what's different about this
yeah so they're all dynamic shapes
except for the ground at the very bottom
but and also hidden hidden from view are
actually two more static static shapes
on the left and right because if we
didn't have those all of the other balls
would sort of like fall to the side out
of out of view but yeah we have we have
the static sort of like delimiters for
our scene but we have a bunch of dynamic
bodies the the balls are all dynamic and
then the the square is also dynamic and
then like I said before the only real
difference between them is that
obviously the squares are rectangle but
it also just has a higher density and so
by giving it a higher density it pushes
everything else what happened there that
was weird it pushes I think it went to
sleep because we didn't do anything for
a while but we were able to it's able to
fall through everything else because it
it knows that it's heavier and that it
should push and apply a larger force to
everything else that's around it and so
by you know using these fundamental
building blocks of what box 2d is you
can sort of construct a lot of really
cool simulations and other fun programs
and actually get interesting game ideas
I am inclined to believe that Angry
Birds started out as somebody messing
around with the you know box 2d or a
physics engine like this and it was
inspired by some other game that I
should look into a little bit but the
creators of that game presumably found
this physics engine and we're like oh
this is cool
I'm gonna put like a tower of blocks
here and it's like throw something at it
and then they realized oh we could make
a game out of this and so I encourage
you if you're ever curious to you know
just experiment things like that
we could probably turn this into a game
I don't know I like this a lot it's a
good like sort of segue from the AB like
you know sort of abstract for lack of a
better word examples that we used
earlier and sort of merges it more into
the realm of like how can we make
something fun with this and so that's
how we're going to sort of move start
moving into the distro today so the main
topic of today's lecture was box 2d is
box 2d and how we use it to make a game
another thing that we
consider is mouse input we haven't
really used it yet
and I believe I've mentioned it before
slightly offhand but love 2d makes it
super easy it's just like we do with
keyboard input we just have a couple
callbacks that are in main dot Lua
mouse pressed and mouse released the
difference between these and keyboard or
key press and key released is that they
also get an x and a y because usually
when you click the mouse or release the
mouse you want to know where it happened
because that's you know obviously
pertinent to what you're doing when
you're using a mouse so these are fired
by love 2d every time you click or
release a mouse button and they they get
the X the Y and the key and you can do
whatever you want with those and just as
we've done in Prior lectures so that we
can use mouse input in other modules
besides main.lua there's a function
called love mouse key pressed and key
release that I implemented in main da
lua you can check those out they're very
similar to how we did the input tables
for the keyboard before but they allow
us to use this functionality inside of
other functions other modules besides
main.lua so let's go ahead and start
looking at this is where we're going to
start sort of looking at the district
for Angry Birds and how and how we can
put take all these pieces and form them
into an actual game so the first thing
we'll do we'll take a look at just a
couple things then we'll take a short
break and then we'll get more into the
meat of it but let me go ahead and clear
out all of these and then we're going to
pull up so that the distro is in Angry
50 and so main Louis here so not a whole
lot is different in here so we have two
states in in our game so we had a start
and a place they'd ever saw before the
start state is like we've done before
the only difference is in this start
state well for one it's running a box 2d
simulation and two we're actually using
mouse input so actually let's look at
main and so you can see where I've added
this which is different than before so
we have love key pressed as we've seen
before
we also have mousepressed and mouse
released and then mouse was press and
mouse was released so those are the main
differences in main da lua
this time as opposed to last prior
lectures which we only had a keyboard
input and as you can see here we have
input tables for keys pressed and
released on the mouse and so we
initialize those to empty on every
update frame just like we've done with
the keyboard and then the update the
input tables get updated in the callback
functions as we've done before and so
that's basically all that's different
about main dalawa this time and that's
sort of how we've tied together the new
mouse functions that we've just looked
at into our game the states that exist
in our game are play state and start
state so very simple very similar to
last a week where we looked at Zelda we
only basically had a start state and a
play state the start state we can see
here just to tie together the last bit
of our usage of the mouse loved mascot
was pressed 1 does anybody know what
this one is
it is left-click so it is at a love to
Dias signs integer values to all your
mouse buttons and one is traditionally
the default value for left-click some
frameworks will use 0 but you know Lua 1
indexed so start with 1 instead of 0 the
the thing about the start state here
that's kind of cool and interesting so
I'm gonna go ahead and play it again
the
the game so we start off and right off
the gate just to make things kind of
interesting rather than just have a
static screen that says you know angry
50 click to start we're actually running
a love to be at box 2d simulation here
just it's a world with a bunch of
squares and so like what kind of bodies
are all of these they're all dynamic
bodies and we've encapsulated them all
just as we did before in the ball pit
example with some invisible static
bodies on the left right and bottom of
the screen because if we didn't have
those static bodies they would just fall
all the way down and the nice thing is
we don't actually have to render
anything so if you want a sort of maybe
an invisible barrier for something in
your game or you want to encapsulate
something something physical you don't
have to render anything you can just
have arbitrarily shaped and positioned
static buddies and that will act as a
container so in that that's all we're
doing there we have a container set for
all of our little square alien guys and
by creating you know I think a hundred
of them and just letting them drop you
know we have this sort of interesting
visual start to our game with very very
minimal effort so we can take a look at
this
so in our start state in it as I said
before we have a world we obviously need
to open a new world anytime we do any
box duty stuff you have to start by
having a loved physics not new world
else you won't be able to run any
simulations we're gonna create a ground
walls and then a bunch of aliens so this
here we can see that we have a table
that we're inserting aliens into but we
have a class called alien so just
anybody want a ballpark what an alien
class ultimately encapsulate so Altima
is
it is yeah that that's definitely a part
of it so the way it looks or its skin so
it does it does have a reference to that
and then more functionally it also
possesses a body and a fixture so rather
than having a bunch of you know bodies
and fixtures that are sort of separated
out and maybe like just in tables at the
surface level of whatever our level just
like wrap them in a class and then we
just can maintain a reference to each
individual aliens body and fixture that
way it's a little bit more encapsulated
it's a little bit more object oriented a
little bit cleaner in my opinion the
alien class can take square or round as
its well it can take anything you want
to as its type so this will ultimately
decide how its rendered and what shape
it gets but if it's square which is the
default so if you just create an alien
with no type it will get a loved physics
rectangle shape so as we saw before
that's just a a box and then if not we
just default a circle shape but you
could program it to taken whatever shape
you want and then just give it that
shape and you know you don't really have
to do much in terms of coding how it
interacts with anything else in terms of
collision at least because thankfully a
box 2d we'll know okay it's a circle it
should you know wrote to it should spin
around and interact with things like a
circle or it's a rectangle so it should
interact with things like it's a box
just nice and convenient and then we'll
just create a fixture here this set user
data function here is important because
we'll see in the context of how we
actually resolve collisions in a
customized way
we'll need user data to be able to
differentiate what gets collided in our
world but at the moment you can just
know that this basically allows us to
pass in to set arbitrary data onto a
fixture so we can say fixture set user
data alien the string alien and what
that means is that fixture has some
customized metadata about it that says
this is an alien you know it's whatever
we want to do with it we could give this
a table as well we could just you know
say the user data is a table and then
has a bunch of information that we can
then use at collision time to perform
different work on it but this set user
data function is how we are able to
resolve collisions between obstacles and
aliens differently than say players and
aliens or even the alien and the ground
because when we do any box2d collision
right the world's taking care of the
collisions for us how do we sort of tell
the world okay when I hit the ground I
want to play a sound but not do anything
if I hit this box at this velocity I
want it to destroy it if I hit the alien
I want the alien to disappear and I want
to play a victory I want to show a
victory label like how do we do all
these different things we do that with
what are called collision callbacks in
the context of box2d and we'll see how
that works but suffice to say user data
will be very important coming coming
forward and then this launched false
actually we don't end up using this so
this is irrelevant but it has a render
function here which just takes in the
bodies x and y and will draw it at the
angle that it's at so that's an
important thing when we before what we
were doing is drawing things via shapes
so loved-up graphics not polygons love
dot graphics not circle of that graphic
style line but if we want to draw a
sprite instead we well we need to draw
it at the right position first of all
right and then things also rotate in
box2d
so we need to draw it at the right angle
so what we do is we can actually query
the body for its X we can query the body
for its Y and we can also query the body
for its angle and then we can draw the
texture and the quad that we want to
using those XY and the angle and that'll
have the effect of drawing a sprite in
the world that mirrors what's going on
in box 2d rather than just a simple
shape so that's that's as simple as it
is for
drawing a sprite instead of a shape you
can see here the 17.5 17.5 st. buddy
know what that's for so 17.5 17.5 at the
end is half of the width and half of the
height of the alien so aliens are 35 by
35 in this game we pass those in this is
the center of origin so when we rotate
something by a center of origin
it basically means where that it
describes where it's going to where the
rotation is going to take place so if if
it's rotated about the top left and we
rotate something it's gonna have the
effect of the sprite sort of like going
around in a circle and sort of an odd
way if we rotate the sprite based on the
center of origin of the actual sprite
itself that'll have the effect of
rotating the sprite on its center right
so you can set that origin wherever you
want to it'll perform a 360 degree
rotation about that point and we're
setting that point to half in to
basically the middle of where we're
drawing the sprite and so they'll have
the effect of when we give it this angle
here itself that body to get angle the
rotation will take place in place
it won't take place it won't be some
sort of weird you know about the
top-left corner rotation which is not
what we want so when you see center of
origin being modified like that you can
sort of assume that it's because we have
an offset and we're trying to find the
center of wherever we're drawing and
rotate about that to do an in-place
rotation but not necessarily you could
also draw something you could also maybe
want maybe you want something like some
sort of magical ball of energy to rotate
about like a rod or something and so you
want it to rotate around a different
center or you know whatever you want
arbitrarily but typically at least
mostly that I've seen this is useful for
making sure that your rotations your in
place rotations are accurately rendered
so any questions about sort of how the
alien class works
all right so that's the alien class
that's the one of this basically the
fundamental building block of our game
the other part is the obstacle right
we have obstacles and we have aliens the
obstacles and aliens are actually very
similar so what's the what what's the
difference between I mean ultimately how
are they how are they similar
they're both dynamic bodies yeah really
the only thing that's different about a
obstacle and an alien is what we do with
them in our scene and how they're
rendered but they function very
similarly there are just dynamic bodies
that we give a shape to and we render
them at that shape with that shape in
this case the obstacle constructor we've
sort of decided to design it such that
it could take a shape horizontal or
vertical which is similar to the type
that we saw before with the alien where
it could be square or circular in this
case if we look back at our sprite sheet
back here we can see there's a ton of
different shapes but the only two shapes
that we're gonna use in the contests of
this game just for this demonstration
are the horizontal clean wooden shape
here and the vertical one that's right
here and so in order to find those out I
had to open up this basically this
sprite in mice with my sprite editor
figure out where the X Y width and
height were and then create a quad
manually off of that and then I edited
the utili wa are not utilit lua the
dependencies that lua
here normally we just create g frames
and the way you use generate quads you
know and you can do that like with the
aliens and with the tiles the tiles
being this the sprite sheet that this
one right here these are 35 by 35 these
are 35 by 35 these are not 35 by 35
these are a bunch of different shapes
and sizes so I went through and
gee frames wood is for manually created
quads here and then there's there's four
because I also added the sort of semi
broken shapes as well but those don't
actually we don't actually use those but
you could decide to turn these into
these on collision perhaps maybe if the
velocity isn't strong enough to break it
necessarily but you want to have some
sort of feedback that you collided with
it you can just set maybe the frame to
one or two on collision for that object
instead of you know two and render it
appropriately but if you're dealing with
a sprite sheet and that sprite sheet has
odd sort of distributions of its sprites
sometimes you have to you know figure
out where the offsets are manually and
do it that way the ideal is that you
don't have to and that you can do it
programmatically but it really depends
on the game whatever what your domain is
and sort of what objects you're
interacting with in the scene any
questions on sort of the wire how as to
that okay cool so back to the obstacle
so there horizontal or vertical and what
that does is it sets the frame to two or
four and the two or four being in G
frames at would the four quads that I
you know sort of had a hand figure out
the coordinates for and really it's not
a whole lot different at that point if
it's a horizontal or a vertical shape
then we need to set its width and height
appropriately because it's going to have
a different width and a different height
if it's vertical
obviously the height is higher than the
width and if it's horizontal the
opposite is true
but they're both a rectangle shape so
you can pass in the width and the height
after you calculate that and give it the
right shape and then ascribe it a
fixture and then set user data in this
case we set user data to obstacle so now
that obstacle the fixture specifically
knows that it's an obstacle as opposed
to being an alien as opposed to being
anything else but supposed to be in the
ground and so when we explore in a few
minutes what
you know with the custom collision world
collision callbacks that we can actually
define all this interesting collision
behavior for this user data is going to
be relevant and then we render it just
like we render the alien as before so
any questions on ups tools and aliens
how they differ how they're the same
cool all right let's take a five-minute
now when we get back we're going to
actually look at the play state we're
gonna look at what makes a level and
we're gonna actually look at how we can
customize the world to resolve
collisions in ways that are relevant to
our game behavior as in how to make
things break when we collide with them
how to make the victory screen pop up
when we've you know destroyed the bird
so on and so forth so alright welcome
back
so before we took a break we were
talking about the aliens and obstacles
that are in our game world that interact
with each other they are sort of the
know the backbone of what makes our game
slash Angry Birds work you know you
throw aliens into the obstacles
obstacles break the other two bad pigs
slash aliens die in the new score up
points but we actually have to model
these interactions and we have to tell
our game our world what to do when these
collisions happen in order for things
more interesting than just things
bouncing off each other to work that's
the default behavior box to Dee's goal
by default is when two things sort of
overlap assuming that they're dynamic
well at least one of them is dynamic is
to push the dynamic body sort of away
until they're no longer overlap
via either position or rotation but
that's not and that's not the gist or
the goal of our game because what we
want to have happen is different things
happen and certain things to disappear
and to you know break and all sorts of
other things to happen when different
kinds of objects interact with different
kinds of objects at differing speeds so
in order to do this we need to define
collision callbacks for our world so a
callback recall is a function
that gets called back when something
happens it's just a something that will
get called at a specific time or later
on and we can define these callbacks for
our world such that when two things
collide with each other it will execute
this callback and then perform you know
the corresponding logic that we've
defined therein and with every collision
in box2d
there are four callbacks that take place
there's begin contact so when two things
begin to overlap or begin to contact one
another and contact so once that ends so
once two objects are pushed away from
each other
pre solve which happens right before the
collision actually gets solved in box2d
meaning that it the things get pushed
away from each other and then post solve
meaning right after they get pushed away
from each other and the post solve in
particular is interesting because it
gets the information about how the
collision needed to resolve so how much
velocity or rotation needed to happen
within that interaction and we will not
be using n contact presov or post saw we
will only be using begin contact because
really that's all we need in order to
model the behavior that we're looking
for because anything that happens in our
game we can just figure it out as soon
as two objects touch each other and
these are things if you're interested in
a tutorial that sort of goes over these
in perhaps a little bit more detail
there's a link here in the slides but
we'll show you how to actually implement
these callbacks yourself you do this via
a function called world set callbacks in
this case F 1 F 2 F 3 F 4 and recall
because Lua is a dynamic language where
functions are first class objects you
can pass in functions as arguments to
other functions and that's what we're
doing here so this is assuming that we
have four functions we've defined called
begin contact and contact pre solve our
PO solve their actual names don't matter
at all these are just sort of the de
facto names for them what matters is
that you have the logic there and you
pass in function objects that perform
something and you can pass in all empty
functions and box2d will still behave as
normal these are only for when you want
more complicated behavior out of your
game than just things bouncing off of
each other and sort of moving relative
to one another
so does that sort of make sense so we'll
see how this actually works so we're
going to help go ahead and open up level
Lua
so level Lua is a container class that
basically has our game level in it
including the world and all the entities
and we sort of update it and are able to
model effectively our you know like a
level from Angry Birds it's really what
it is it has a world so the level has
its own world with 300 positive Y
gravity as we saw before it has a table
called destroyed bodies and we'll see
that in a second and then here we have
four functions starting on line 22 we
have begin contact which is a long
function and then we have n contact pre
solve and post solve these are the four
callback functions that I alluded to
just a few seconds ago they take in
slightly different signatures the first
three take a be and collision and then
the last one takes in a B collision and
then a normal impulse and a tangent
impulse which are the forces that it
needed to apply in order to push apart
the two objects like I said we won't be
using these three functions but you
might there might be a situation where
you need to use those functions maybe
you want n contact because in your game
two objects attached to one another
right when they collide maybe they're
magnetic or something and then once they
pull apart maybe you want like a
particle effect or something to show
that they've separated or something and
then pre solve and posts all posts all
pre solve offhand I can't think of a use
case but post solve could be useful for
depending on your game whether you need
to just figure out maybe the the amount
of force that they needed to separate
maybe you multiply that by some amount
and cause some sort of dramatic effect
those will ultimately dependent on the
domain of your game the important
function that we'll be using today is
the first one begin contact and notice
that we've defined these four functions
even if these three are just empty but
we pass in as I said before the set
callbacks function takes in those four
functions
and notice another interesting thing
because of Lewis dynamic nature line 11
you can see that we have level in it
which is the constructor for our level
class within the constructor we are
defining more functions you can define
functions as many layers a deep as you
want to and you can even return
functions from functions which are
called higher-order functions really you
do whatever you want to in this case
we're just defining the collision
callbacks here inside of our knit but
you could put them most anywhere you
want to you could have them outside of
the class you could have them wherever
you want you could have them be global
functions in your main dot Lua which I
don't know how I feel about that but you
could do whatever you want to as long as
the functions exist and you can
reference their symbols you can pass
them into self dot world set callbacks
and now whenever a collision it happens
in the world period it's going to call
all four of those functions at each
stage of each collision so you can see
that potentially getting a little bit
hairy if you were to scale high enough
with all of your logic if you had a
million lines of code in each of these
and it's executing million lines of code
per collision you could run into trouble
but fortunately we're not going anywhere
near that the gist of begin contact so
it takes in an A and a B and a collision
we're not we don't end up using the
collision itself we just use the a and
the B because that's all we need for our
game world the a and the B are what do
we know what a and the B are the two
objects miss do you know whether it's a
body or a fixture
it'll be the fixture the fixtures
collide with each other not the bodies
so when you have a body recall that the
fixture attaches the shape to a body the
body is just a position and velocity
container for a bunch of fixtures the
body is the each individual fixture
collides with other things other
fixtures in your game world and so
recall that before we had fixture set
user data because that's what we ended
up needing to have data on when we do
the collisions we check to see you know
via get user data what something is or
what metadata we've given to that
fixture and we can then we can then
separate different classes of objects
this way we can say oh this object was
an alien or this object was an obstacle
or this object was the ground and then
we can say oh did we fly with an alien
it was the collision between an alien
and the ground if it was okay let's play
like a bounce sound effect and if it was
between an alien and the other alien the
player and the other alien and the
velocity was fast enough okay the alien
should die right we can do all we can do
arbitrary things and so the way that
that I've programmed it here such that
we can see what two things interacted
with each other and this is a very
simple use of user data is and all we
all we're doing in this code base is
just assigning strings to fixtures but
you could assign tables to fixtures with
arbitrary amounts of data and do all
sorts of things in this case we're only
using strings so I create a table an
empty table and then I just assign a
table at that string true and then I can
just query that table do I have a key
player and a key alien do I have a key
obstacle and a key obstacle you know
this is how you can sort of figure out
what your two objects were because a
could be a player and B could be an
obstacle a could be an obstacle and B
could be the player so you have to sort
of take both of that into consideration
so it allows us to do if types obstacle
and types player so a collision between
the player and an obstacle if it's fast
enough then we can destroy the obstacle
that's
what we do here so I take the absolute
value of the velocity on the X and the y
so I do del X of L y gets the body's
linear velocity so linear velocity is
just where it's moving in the world and
it returns two values because the
velocity has an X and a y component and
then we sum it here by taking its
absolute value of both both parts and
adding it together so if it's moving
fast on the x axis but not fast on the y
axis or if it's not moving fast on
either orbits moving fast on both we
have a sense like in general like what's
the average velocity of our object like
if it's moving fast on any of the axes
we can assume that that's sufficient
force to cause an object to get
destroyed right so we do if the sum
velocity is greater than 20 just an
arbitrary value that it came up with
that seemed appropriate
then we're going to do this table insert
self dot destroyed bodies which we saw
earlier and then the obstacles body now
why are we inserting that value here as
opposed to maybe just like destroying it
inside this function
destroying the body the fixture yeah in
this case yeah you're still referencing
later in the code box2d maintains a
reference to all of the bodies all of
the fixtures in your in your world
regardless of whether you've delay them
or not but if you delete them while it's
in the middle of a like checking for
collision it'll try to do another
collision with that destroyed body and
you'll get a crash or a stack overflow
error I found I experienced both of
those you don't want to ever delete or
destroy anything while inside a
collision callback for your world it
will cause horrible things to happen so
what we do is we maintain a reference to
everything that we're going to destroy
by just inserting it so if we do table
that insert the body
of whatever we want in two destroyed
bodies we can then loop over that after
this after the world updates and then
just destroy them one by one outside of
the update function and the reason that
we are passing in the body and not the
fixture is when we destroy the body it
destroys all the fixtures associated
with that body as well so we're just
destroying the top-level container here
in this case it doesn't matter too much
whether we destroy a fixture or a body
because they're sort of it's a
one-to-one relationship but if you had
let's say a body that has like five
fixtures on it and if that entire thing
collides with something else and you
want to destroy that entire thing you
want to destroy the body not an
individual fixture because when you
destroy the body it destroys all the
fixtures not just the one fixture so
that's why we're doing that's why we're
deleting the body adding the body to
destroyed bodies and then later
performing a delete off of that the
function is destroy here so online 157
well 155 to 159 this is where we
actually iterate over everything that we
wanted to flag or that we've flagged as
destroyed and we destroy it so if body
it not body is destroyed destroy it and
then once we destroy it we're going to
go down here and end up actually
removing the obstacle and the alien
class from our list of aliens and
obstacles because that will mean that
maintains a reference to like what we're
drawing and we wanted to also delete
that so not only do we want to delete
the object from the world we want to
delete the objects that we've created
that are sort of a wrapper for the
bodies and fixtures and also the drawing
of our aliens so it no longer gets drawn
to the scene basically so yeah don't
ever delete a body or a fixture inside
your callbacks always flag them and
delete them afterwards basically don't
delete in the middle of a world update
function call which we see here notice
that this takes place 152 we're doing
self world update and then on 155 to 159
we've populated destroyed bodies via the
collision callback that we defined up
above so in here this is where we can
actually destroy everything this is
outside of the update function here are
the world update function we don't need
to worry about Stack Overflow or you
know a segfault which we get by deleting
something while it's in the middle of
processing its update its collisions so
unfortunate bug if you ever find
yourself running into stack overflows or
seg faults in your collision callbacks
make sure you're not deleting anything
so but we can see here it's very similar
with the behavior we defined between
obstacles and the player between
obstacles and aliens and between the
player and alien ultimately it's check
to see whether the average of its
velocity is greater than a certain
number in this case 20 and if it is flag
it as destroyed so if the player hits
the alien destroyed if an obstacle hits
the alien destroy it and it's sort of
similar to how it works in Angry Birds
like when you when you throw something
at a structure in Angry Birds and you
know a piece of debris falls off of it
and hits it hits the pig usually kills
the pig too and if your bird hits the
pig that usually kills the pig but if
you're not moving fast enough or if a
piece of debris isn't moving fast enough
it'll just sort of nudge the pig it
won't actually kill the pig so that's
why we're taking all this into
consideration we're not just doing a
blind delete off of the uh the bodies in
our code we're actually making sure is
it also moving fast enough
ie does it have enough force and if it
does then perform the code then then
perform the deletion flaggin is being
deleted and so once again that's why
user data is important because that's
how we're able to because notice in the
callback we just get an A and a B and
those are always gonna be fixtures
fixtures in order for it to know what
kind of a fixture it is you know whether
it belongs to a player or an alien we
need to give it some information so the
set user data Flags the fixtures as
being of a specific type
and then we can fetch it here with get
user data and then actually perform the
relevant game logic any questions as to
how this works am i checking with the
two obstacles with each other I might
not be and that Kay and you you should
the in that case since we're not they'll
just bump into each other but yeah if we
want if we wanted two wooden obstacles
to like destroy each other if they hit
fast enough you would just do the same
thing here types if types obstacle I
guess but in this case because they both
the same key you would have to do if
types obstacle if types let's see how
we're doing it again so types obstacles
true type obstacles true you would be
you would say if types obstacle and not
types alien not types player not there's
a there's a cleaner way to do it yeah
yeah that's true yeah there's there's
there's a lot of ways and I if I were to
reengineer this I would also abstract
out this code and make it a function
because pretty much the same code
between all three of these but just to
illustrate and just for simplicity
because it's pretty similar interactions
didn't really put too much engineering
forethought into it definitely if you
expand upon it I would I would recommend
doing that but that's the gist of making
our world behave beyond just resolving
collisions and pushing obstacles away
from each other which is the default
behavior so we set the callbacks we're
good now things when they interact with
each other they'll behave differently
they'll trigger different behavior we
have this thing called a launch marker
an alien launch marker anybody know what
that might be
yeah so it's the dots that show the
trajectory it's one the alien being
rendered on the left side of the screen
without any physics applied to it
that's click-and-drag a ball and it also
renders a trajectory and when you
release the mouse it launches a actual
box to the alien traveling in the
direction that that trajectory sort of
foretells if we look at a lien launch
marker here it basically it maintains a
reference to whether we're aiming or not
so it's got a couple of states got like
a launch state and an aiming state an
alien that will have a reference to
eventually which will spawn and we'll
give it an impulse so an impulse is
effectively setting its velocity
immediately to some value as opposed to
something over time we can apply force
to an object which would be like you
driving your car up against something
and then gradually accelerating that's
applying force we can also apply an
impulse by going full speed with our car
and hitting an object and that will sort
of have the effect of applying an
impulse at a certain velocity when we
drag our alien and then we release it we
want to apply an impulse in the opposite
direction of where we're dragging but
based on a certain amount well I scaled
it by 10 but you can have it be
arbitrary and then the trajectory sort
of models where it's going and the
trajectory is calculated via these lines
here so from line 92104 there's a
formula for in that box 2d set of
tutorials that actually shows you how to
calculate an estimated trajectory given
an impasse starting impulse and a
starting position which is this formula
here it's a semi complicated the article
goes into detail as to how it works but
it effectively calculates one sixtieth
of a second assuming that we're running
our simulation at one sixtieth of a
second it will over 90 iterations here
one to ninety calculate each individual
step of that simulation and then I only
render every 5 here so if I
Maude five is zero then I'll actually
end up drawing a circle at trajectory X
trajectory Y trajectory X&Y being here
shifted X shifted Y being the starting
location and then we multiply by one
sixteenth of a second which will give us
the scalar for this impulse here and
then with gravity we have to do this I
squared plus I times 1/2 times the
gravity that on the y axis times one
sixtieth squared the article wasn't a
little bit more detail as to how it
works but that's it converted into
source code but it's effectively a
gravity simulation and a velocity
simulation over time and by rendering it
based on 90 iterations which is at 1 and
1/2 seconds at 1/6 of a second we can
tell we can forecast where exactly we're
going and then when we apply this
impulse X&Y the ball will actually
travel that alien will actually travel
in that direction
at that exact trajectory so that's the
complicated part of the launch marker
the other part is that it has a couple
of states like I said before so when we
click and we're not launched it should
go into aiming mode and so if we're
aiming then we're gonna set our rotation
to actually rotations not relevant
because the this was before I ended up
using the predictive trajectory method
the shifted X&Y though those are
relevant because that's the sort of
starting location for your trajectory
and that's wherever your mouse is and we
clamp it so that doesn't go past a
certain limit on the left or the right
so that it stays within like a box area
but this will be whenever you let go of
the mouse that'll be where we spawn the
box2d alien and apply an impulse in the
negative direction relative to where
we've moved the mouse so if we move the
mouse to the left and down its going to
spawn it's going to negate that with an
impulse going up and to the right if
that makes sense and that's what's shown
by the trajectory
and then aside from that it renders
different things depending on whether or
not what state were in so if we haven't
launched it'll render just the alien if
we're an aiming mode then it should
actually render the render and calculate
the trajectory otherwise it's just
render the alien and so once we release
the mouse so was released one and we're
aiming launched is true spawn an alien
so we create a new alien with self world
it's round
give it we started at shifted X and
shifted Y but we said it's a linear
velocity to the same values that we
calculated before so it's base X minus
shifted x times ten so the times ten is
a scalar amount and then it's a the base
x is the where we've moved it
effectively or no base x is where it
starts and shifted x is where we've
moved it and so by by subtracting
shifted from the base we get the sort of
negative direction that we want to
effect the impulse and then we the
impulses set here with linear velocity
and then we do we also set it to have a
restitution of 0.4 recall restitution is
bounciness so our alien bounces a little
bit when hits the ground and then
anybody know what angular damping might
be any guesses angular damping is when
it rotates basically friction on its
rotation so that when it rotates on the
ground it doesn't roll indefinitely if
we said that if we don't set that it'll
just roll forever and ever and ever and
ever which is now we want we all want it
to stop as at a certain point because
once it stops we know okay now we can
get the next alien ready to launch right
and that's the gist behind the the
launch marker how we get like how we
render a trajectory for the math on that
a little bit more in detail I would
explore that URL it goes into it in a
pretty good detail I use that as a
reference for creating this bit of code
here
but yeah effectively is it just
rendering a bunch of circles with that
trajectory and calculating it over 90
ticks 90 sort of frame iterations back
to the level oh sorry any questions
overall it's like how the launch marker
works all right so then we have an
aliens table and obstacles table head
shape for the ground and then we just
create an alien 2 destroy spawn a few
obstacles here so in this case two
vertical obstacles and a horizontal one
position such that the horizontal one is
over the vertical ones and they're
spaced apart such that the aliens are in
the middle of them then the ground here
we give the ground some friction 0.5 and
that's pretty much it for setting up our
level so if we wanted to after you know
this point we have the foundation
necessary to really spawn arbitrary
levels with you know admittedly simple
obstacles at this point but we could set
you know because all we're doing here is
just simple insertions to our aliens and
obstacles table we could create you know
pretty much any level just by maybe in
data specifying like level could be like
a table and then aliens could be another
table and then maybe all it is is just a
like x equals some value and then y
equals some value and then obstacles is
sort of the same thing and then all we
do is just we iterate over this level
definition and we just say new alien for
every you know table in here and then
new obstacle for every table in here and
then now your levels are data-driven
it's easy just to make levels you don't
have to code really much and you can put
this in a separate file be like levels
lua and then just load individual levels
at a time level one equals you know
levels would be the
top-level container and then you would
have like one equals all of this and
then two equals another one three equals
another one and then you know you're not
really programming as much as you are
just sort of laying things out in data
super nice and concise that's the nice
thing about a language like Lua is that
you can and it's sort of the same thing
in JavaScript you know with Jason you
can just define things as data and then
write a script to go over it and
construct your actual relevant data
structures that way
in your code that way when you know you
have the foundation like we have now or
you can think in terms of obstacles and
aliens you can construct levels like so
and obviously you could go a lot more
complicated with this all we're doing is
having like a very simple sort of almost
you know boring static obstacles that
you're not they're not static in the
technical sense because they're dynamic
objects but they all they really do is
just stand there and then fall over but
if you wanted like a pulley system or
you know maybe something that's like
shaped in like a giant head or something
you can create arbitrarily complex
objects that way using joints and if
you're curious I recommend to look into
the documentation for love to do a
little bit more and especially their the
weld joints are what you would use to
like combine pieces and arbitrary shapes
but you could easily take this to the
next level and start to create in you
know that same level definition
arbitrarily shaped welded together
obstacles but that would be I think a
next step if you're looking to take this
beyond just one level I would say think
in terms of how can I get my game world
represented in a very simple data like
way because not only does it make it
easier for you to create content it
allows you to shift that burden to
somebody else and allow you to you know
give the task of creating levels less to
a programmer may be more to somebody who
has just a design background who isn't
as comfortable writing code and allow
you to create the engine that then
constructs the game world based off of
this data
any questions as to how we've set things
up here okay so we have the ground we
have a background a background is just a
simple class that renders a static image
that you can you can scroll the image
with left or right but we don't end up
using it much it's relevant in Angry
Birds because in Angry Birds they have a
camera and the camera pans left to right
depending on how far away the fortress
is from your slingshot so that's in
there if you want to experiment with it
at all and experiment to make a moving
camera maybe use like timer tween to
tween the camera or you know just have
it track the alien if you want larger
worlds but we don't end up using it in
the distro as much our update function
is simple we update the launch marker
update the world and then we process all
the bodies that we flag is being
destroyed which we've already seen we
reset destroyed bodies to an empty table
because we've processed all of them we
actually remove from our level the
obstacle objects so that they're no
longer rendered and we no longer try to
reference the bodies that are destroyed
and then notice here too when we destroy
the obstacle we're playing a sound
effect inside this bit of code so we
just do you know G sounds and then I put
five wouldn't sound effects in there
just for variability it will pick a
random one and then using two string at
the number just create break one two
three four five here and then stop and
play it same thing here I have a sound
called kill for when we destroy an alien
so when we flag an alien is destroyed
and we remove it from the scene
we should also call that sound effect
and then if we end up if the alien stops
moving in our scene the player we can
get a reference to it here self-taught
launch marker alien as opposed to like
any aliens in our scene when it stops
moving so we get the average of its
velocity in this less than one point
five so not perfectly still because it's
kind of tedious to wait that long
but almost still
we destroy the alien and then we create
a new launch marker we destroy the alien
so that the world doesn't keep a
reference to it and then we just create
a brand new marker which has the effect
of instantiating a new alien there when
we relaunch and then here if there are
no more aliens in our scene if we've
destroyed all of the aliens in this case
there's only ever one but there could
easily with a little more work be a few
more aliens in the scene if it's set to
zero then go back to the start which we
saw before when we finally killed the
alien and then all we're doing here is
deferring rendering to the individual
objects we want to render the launch
marker the alien the obstacle we render
ground tiles so recall from our ground
example before we were just using a line
in edge shape to represent the ground
but if we look at our game we're not
actually we don't actually have it's a
little hard to see because I'm in 720
but there's actually a ground tile here
at the very bottom a bunch of them and
even though we have all of those tiles
all we're doing to detect collision is
just an edge shape so what we're doing
is just beyond having the edge shape in
our scene we draw that tile which is
frame 12 in our sprite sheet from
negative virtual width to virtual bit
times 2 so 3 screen widths total and
then we just do it in increments of 35
pixels because that's how why the tile
is and that'll just create a bunch of
the same tile at the very bottom of our
screen so just just a graphical thing
not really necessarily functional we
have the edge shape already in our scene
but just to make the ground look a
little larger than 1 pixel tall and then
if we haven't launched anything we
should display some instructions here
and then if we're at no aliens left then
we should just display the victory
screen and the victory thing will last
for just a little bit of time because
even though self-taught aliens is 0 this
bit of code doesn't read
stir until after the velocity of our
moving alien slows down sufficiently so
this will get called when we were like
just about to finally stop moving and
then we check to see ok do we indeed
have no aliens left if not time to go
back to the start we've completed the
level and then you obviously would just
change this to go to be next level if
you ended up implementing more levels in
your game so it's just one beyond that
that's pretty much all of the code
that's in this example it's um fairly I
would say unsophisticated relative to
prior examples but mainly the burden is
learning how to use the physics engine
the Box 2d physics engine which itself
is quite a few functions it's some of
the longest documentation on love duties
wiki I think but the principles are
pretty simple in my opinion I think it's
actually quite easy to get to get
rolling with a lot of cool features a
lot like oh the vast majority of which I
don't think we even really cover it at
least in terms of what you can do with
compound objects and joints and things
like that which really start to go into
the world of sort of more sophisticated
interesting physical simulations things
like I alluded to before pulleys and
tanks and other things like that some
features that we could look at
potentially expanding upon if we wanted
to make our game more interesting is
more shapes for our objects so if we
look at our sprite sheet here we can see
there are things like roofs and circles
and things like that so more interesting
obstacles beyond just square rectangular
shaped obstacles go back to so like I
said before compound obstacles so a
bunch of things put together via joints
so pulleys motors motors weld joints
which you can use to you could have fix
a roof to a square and then have like
two pieces that are sort of tied
together and you can make arbitrarily
complex and shaped things and just be
really interesting and that big thing
that body with all these fixtures will
collide just as any other thing would
thanks to box 2d
as I alluded to before instead of having
levels to sort of be hard-coded into our
level class maybe define them in a Lua
file called like levels da lua and then
just have aliens be a table obstacles be
a table and then whatever else however
more complicated you want to get with
your game you can add more things but
just have it be represented as simple
data structures so aliens that maybe
have different shooting mechanics so if
you've played Angry Birds you're
familiar with the fact that some birds
will split off into multiple birds some
birds will like dive and like go super
fast and like break through all the
obstacles in their path some birds will
explode and then their explosion affects
all the obstacles around them so there's
a lot of different gameplay mechanics
you can implement using different types
of birds or aliens and then different
obstacle materials is another direction
we could go and it's supported out of
the box with the sprite sheet that I
provided because it has sheets for like
metal and glass and explosive material
so there's a lot of different
interesting things you could do just by
changing up what materials are using in
the game and obviously those will have
different densities and behave in
different ways so assignment 5 is a
fairly simple assignment so this is just
as I alluded to before the task here is
to split the bird that you shoot a by
pressing spacebar when it's in the bird
the alien when it's in the air press
spacebar and have it split into three so
you have your one that you're shooting
already so it should just shoot off two
more one that's angled higher when it's
angled lower and all of those should be
interactable with your game world and
that's really it so if you can do that
then it'll show that you know how to
affect the Box 2d game world next time
next lecture we'll be talking about the
theme is going to be Pokemon but we'll
be talking about more generally RPGs and
turn-based games of that nature it won't
maybe necessarily look quite as pretty
as this but we'll be striving for a
similar sort of overworld that we can
walk around and then engage in fairly
simple like turn-based battles and stuff
like that and also what we're talking
about user interfaces and like things
like dialogue and stuff like that
but that was it for lecture six Angry
Birds I'll see you next time thank you